[Music]
prepare yourself for a journey beyond
what is possible walt disney animation
studios proudly presents strange world a
new motion picture event brace yourself
travel past space and time to a place of
infinite mystery unlike anything you've
ever seen
where in the world are we
[Music]
we are in way over our heads
i'm not an explorer i'm a farmer
[Music]
we need to get out of here
if you want to back out this is the time
to do it
really
no
messing with you come on let's make
history
[Music]
buzz lightyear mission log stardate 3901
after a full year of being marooned our
first hyper speed test flight is a go
who are you talking uh no one you were
narrating again i was not just doing the
mission log you do know no one ever
listens to that i know that narrating
helps me focus
ready captain light you ready as i'll
ever be commander hawthorne this is
exciting a new adventure i'm gonna grant
you four minutes to be off planet but
then you come right back to us
to infinity and beyond
and you are clear for hyperlaunch
buzz that was utterly terrifying and i
regret having joined you
buzz like you to star command come in
star command why don't they answer
hey
the robots the what
what is happening right now
alicia oh no that's my grandmother but
sucks how long were we gone
62 years seven months and five days
what
i hope you're ready for action because
all we needed was a pilot for what to
destroy the alien ship
i have a plan and i have a team darby
can take any three things and make them
explode i do this and they shave a
little time off my sentence okay and
what about you well i thought this was
going to be like a fun boot camp workout
thing
but it is not
did i get it pretty close i need that
[Music]
the probability of survival with an
inexperienced crew is 38.2 hmm seems a
bit low
[Music]
with this recording speak or select one
[Music]
to infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it no
not like that
sorry it's the thing your grandma and i
used to do yeah
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
uh
uh
[Music]
hey
wow
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
oh if
you want to see something cool
gracias the legend will never die
you died i have nigh life and how many
times have you died already uh
no persian bull doesn't need a spotter
watch
what a god always lands on his feet
watch
you are down to your last life mama luna
is always on the lookout for a new lap
cat i have no lap cat i am [ __ ] boots
not anymore
[Music]
this is a person potty pickles that's
your party so this is where dignity goes
to die
you don't look like the pickles well
you don't look like a cat
full disclosure i'm a therapy dog why
were my belly
hard buzz
they found me
goldilocks and the three bears crying
make her talk
excuse me my darling we're looking for
the legendary [ __ ] boots have you
perhaps
seen him
what a puss in boots
he
is me
oh
[Applause]
normally i have a sword he's like a
whole thing okay
get that cat dead or alive will be just
right bounty hunters kitties
i need your help whenever i came up with
you things go wrong cool another member
of the team i'm pussy's therapy dog
definitely not finally you need therapy
oh i have got to learn how to do that
lives flashing before your eyes pray for
mercy from persian birds
[Music]
espresso
[Music]
i don't trust you trust me
you gotta trust him look at those eyes
you call that cute no
i'm with the paws am i doing it stop
you're gonna give yourself a harness
[Music]
wow
i did not see that coming
[Music]
we need a new samurai
[Music]
hey this is the training montage isn't
it
don't forget to land on your
feet
focus
the smell of victory
i have something to tell you i am your
father what no i'm not
pause the fury the legend of
[Music]
all
egg
tv night with my pro
[Applause]
you're going on a date with lois so
disrespectful
oh
hey there little fella
wake up buddy it is
[Music]
with other animals this just seems gross
we need gross smelling stuff is one of
the greatest joys of being a dog next to
licking any part of your body and i lick
myself all the time well that explains
the breath
superman i am lulu and you will kneel
before me
oh aren't you a little ray of sunshine
what's going on
[Music]
invulnerable i should be a lot more dead
right now right all of us have
superpowers
still working out the kinks i didn't see
anything
are you okay my best friend is in danger
and you have to help me you know what
they say about dogs don't you never feed
us chocolate we love unconditionally
baby we're just a bunch of shelter pets
but we're stronger than you think
we'll help you get your dumbo in the
back
it's deployed canines here what is a k-9
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
why could i have gotten a magic hammer
or something
what do i have here
oh squishy bros
that better be a licensed toy or i will
freak out
[Music]
okay
this is it everyone
we're here
to have some fun trapping
no storm troopers no tie fighters no
threat of annihilation
best vacation ever
summer's about to end and we're all
about to go our separate ways it's a
vacation relax hello there who are you
obi-wan kenobi
what is in this come on out in the sun
come on out and have fun we are on
holiday it's not that kind of holiday
one never knows how long a moment will
last you must learn to enjoy yourself
what do you know about vacations
go jabba go job huh
the trip isn't about the destination
it's about the journey
go go go go
[Music]
who's next try not to lose a hand it's
kind of a thing in our family
[Music]
it's a
it's a i'm not saying it it's a snack
[Music]
what's the first thing that pops into
your head when i say chip and dale i bet
it's these guys but certainly the second
would be those rascally cartoon
chipmunks chip and dale
what if i did something
like into
[Music]
good good i love it
[Music]
just want to remind you guys i'll be at
fancon this afternoon hey watch out
i'm keeping myself fit and you know my
updated modern look don't you think
you'd have more fans here if chip did
these events with you i haven't thought
about them in a while i should give them
a call see how life's treating him life
is the worst
which is why you need good insurance
a message on my landline
i don't like that
i know you're still mad about rescue
rangers getting cancelled but i just got
a call from the police and i need your
help
i searched the perimeter no clues why
would there be six missing tunes in a
month and not one clue
oh no
dale you look
different it's no secret i had the cgi
surgery what's been up with you you know
this that other vague things to fill the
space of this conversation cool
we can see what we can find out and then
pass it along to the officer that that's
all we're gonna do so you're saying the
rescue rangers are back yes
you two come poking around where you
don't belong and i can't have that run i
gotta go
what are you looking at honestly your
weird dead eyes
over here go get them
this is awesome
[Music]
i was always more of an alvin and the
chipmunks person you
monster
it was like professional
same time
you owe me a non-brand specific cola
what that was crazy
somebody calls me this book
this is incredible
oh this is the welcome to the bat cave
that's the batmobile and the bad
computer who's the new kid john this is
batman's son damien
well he's obviously not invulnerable
reminds me of us when we first met i was
nicer
what are you doing here aliens are
taking over the globe
[Music]
come on farm boy we gotta go save our
dance
[Music]
all right justice dweebs let's do this
thing
[Music]
on the outside
the five of you are villains
predators
remorseless sociopaths
oh stop you making me bless
we're the bad guys
and this is the crew mr snake serpentine
safe cracking machine imagine houdini
but with no arms jackpot yes miss
tarantula our in-house tech wizard
where'd you learn to do that mostly
youtube mr piranha he's brave crazy
what's up papa
and mr shark master of disguise his
greatest trick stealing the mona lisa
disguised as the mona lisa
and rounding out the crew is me the big
bad wolf we may be bad but we're so good
at it
we're out of here so long suckers
well this just got a little weird
if only we were given a chance to be
anything more than criminals if you want
to stay out of jail you need to go good
what are you doing we're gonna pretend
to go good the bad guys become the good
guys so we can stay in the band guys
it's fantastic wolf you're a genius
welcome to the first day of the rest of
your best life look it's a cat stuck in
a tree what does your heart tell you to
do a good person would smack it in it
stab it saute this is so obvious i want
you to save it
the good guys we're more than just scary
villains they love us you're such a good
boy
maybe i don't want to be a what a bad
guy no no no
we'll always be bad guys
let's try something simpler i'm going to
give you a push-pull just for me no to
share this is going to taste extra
squeaky
nope
sucker
i'll teach you the [ __ ]
totally worth it
[Music]
how did you get how have you been
it's a long story
is this the room you grew up in uh it is
but uh my my dorm room is very adult
right no of course
hey are these your drawings what no no
good
i missed you too
okay
so
what are you doing here
i mean i i thought i'd
never see you again
want to get out of here
[Music]
i'm
grounded
bummer
is spider-man grounded
[Music]
i mean
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hello there now i know what you're
thinking crikey a black cat he's gonna
bring me bad luck
shows what you know about luck
let's drop some knowledge
luck is different all around the world
like in scotland but a black cat like me
is considered very lucky
remember kids don't try this at home
name's bob by the way and this is the
land of luck
morning jerry
we work behind the scenes to create
those wee lucky and unlucky moments that
make up your everyday life
like these guys an entire team thinking
up the jammy lack that kind that makes
you feel like a million bucks
okay maybe a hundred bucks of course
then there's the other team
working on the not-so-jammy kind of luck
and they sure love what they do
well you humans are a complicated lot
and that's why things run so smoothly
here because no human has ever stepped
foot in this place and with a little bit
of luck they never will
uh
where am i
oh you gotta be kidding
[Music]
um
oh about that hustle am i right
breakfast is ready
[Music]
this happened already what did you say
our ancestors had a mystical connection
with red pandas i'm kidding this little
quirk runs in our family
[Music]
little meimei
but maybe i like this new me
mama's girls
[Music]
quick stretch little snack and here we
go
sonic i love that you want to help make
a difference
if you're being reckless don't worry
nobody's gonna get hurt
pretending to be batman blue justice
trademark pending
you're still just a kid
trust me there will come a moment when
your powers will be needed
but you don't choose that moment that
moment chooses you i just got goosebumps
wait a second did you steal that from
oprah
papa's got a brand new stash
since i've been gone i've discovered the
source of ultimate power
that sounds big
it's been on my vision board for years
hope i'm not too late i'm sorry who are
you
tales okay this is what we're gonna do
step one light taunting step two i have
no idea
[Music]
that wasn't too bad
today's forecast calls for a 100 chance
of adventure
[Music]
return to sender
face it you're never going to get my
power
do i look like i need your power
where
are my manners sonic meet knuckles
summer
a time for romantic fireworks
delicious hot dogs and watercraft
recreation is about to get way
more
lit
with some sweet summer jams
[Music]
oh
[Music]
disney plus presents a mickey summer
spectacular oh yeah
too hot for cable tv
[Music]
oh
the wonderful summer of mickey mouse
streaming july 8th only on disney plus
oh
bye
oh
no
oh no no no
oh
oh
[Music]
god
oh
bye
dad i don't want to stop your flow but
can you pass the pilaf oh
god that's butter you know what butter's
better
you have seven days to make your payment
seven it's gonna be okay bob
happy hopeful
kissy lips
my please louise don't go down there
it's dangerous
did you mean to wave your arms all over
the place while falling into the hole
because if so you nailed it yes it all
went great
sister please
i'd like to report a
a thing happened
what do we do ideas go oh oh what's this
thing
i'm so nervous
i know can you believe it
[Music]
that feels nice i know i know don't rub
my sesame seeds off i won't don't worry
they're a cute couple i give them a year
[Music]
i have pointy ones too look
who are you how did you get a ring my
name is jon stewart and if i told you
you wouldn't believe me
what the hell
at last
jon stewart of earth what you possess
singular will welcome to the green
lantern corps
after years of bloody war the owen
security net was disabled hal jordan and
millions of thanagarians died that day
they will pay well she's fun
sinestro thrives on chaos and death get
ready for a fight annihilate them
i've been up against that kind of
barrier my whole life
it hasn't stopped
coordinate set
um
let's go
in a secret place deep inside the forest
the golden egg has chosen i'm a master
rabbit candidate the city rabbit they
make sure every kid gets all of their
easter eggs young rabbits get some
special training if you want to become a
master rabbit you have to take
responsibility you're a rabbit yourself
i know how to get the eggs that's mount
chicken tomorrow we'll steal all the
eggs from up there and on easter sunday
we'll smash them do you trust me with
all our hearts
[Music]
perhaps now fox will have to join forces
with a rabbit to save easter
[Music]
together
together
oh i want to pack you all over
this is it amy moment of truth
remember might be he's the success don't
screw
[Applause]
[Music]
when your uncle upon and i went
searching for the hamster of darkness
what the
finding you
was the best thing
that ever happened to me
i can't believe we got to be seen with
that freak chicken here everybody laughs
at me dad would you expect he's mostly
chicken no he's mostly hair chicken
sounds like they're cheering for you
chicken hair chicken hair chicken
if i can bring back the hamster of
darkness everyone shall accept me
oh i'm okay
need a guide i'm meg
follow in my footsteps and you'll be
okay well that's too bad looks like
we'll have to head back
follow me
[Music]
to enter the temple one must pass the
three deadly trials
why can't it ever be two trials
captain
i'm going down don't move
all of us are born with things that make
us different
who's ready to ride
[Music]
the only choice we have is recognize
that our differences are what makes us
special
here we go
oh please
you couldn't have brought the extra
large whip could you meg
how many flying hairs have you ever seen
you have wings don't you i can't lie
you can watch
i can't fly
this is the day pass mark two embarks on
his journey around the world in 80 days
no less thank you everyone thank you
my sweet little baby boy going around
the world i don't think so
mom
i need to explore any cause i am tired
of living in the shadow you know what
specs i'm tired of living in a shadow
too how about tomorrow morning i break
you out of this crib and we get on that
early ferry together around the world
[Music]
bring my baby home
hello mama's boy
[Music]
[Applause]
what brings you two into this jungle we
had this idea of beating juan frog de
leon's
by walking how old school well how would
you do it by flying frogs can't fly
frogs who build planes can
on frog's book
[Music]
now let's get the ferry there and finish
your trip
wow
[Music]
it's so incredible
[Music]
engine stopped working no need to panic
we're doomed there we go
hmm quicksand how far can your tongue
[Music]
i
reach
bye